i
[Música]
ah
cataluña implantada un plan piloto para
impartir clases de la religión islámica
a partir de este curso 2020 2021 en sus
escuelas públicas este plan ya estaba
contemplado en el acuerdo firmado en el
92 entre el gobierno español y comisión
islámica de españa para garantizar a
todos los alumnos musulmanes pues una
enseñanza de religión islámica como ya
ocurre y pagan los alumnos católicos
pero este plan levantó una polémica
sobre la laicidad en españa y sobre todo
en sus escuelas asociaciones critican
que la religión todavía en españa- se
enseñe como catequesis y según ellos
debería más bien enseñarse con un
enfoque histórico o cultural de hecho el
propio ministro el catalán de educación
dijo que estaba abierto a replantear
este modelo pero hasta que no cambie
defendió este plan que según él
garantiza igualdad de condiciones para
todas las religiones
[Música]
en 2021 escocia se convertirá en el
primer país del mundo en incorporar en
sus planes de enseñanza los derechos de
los gays lesbianas bisexuales y
transgénero en una ley que ha sido
calificada de histórica por parte de
activistas mientras tanto en inglaterra
a partir de este ciclo escolar que
comenzó este mes de septiembre todos los
profesores de escuelas secundarias
deberán enseñar sobre la diversidad
sexual y la identidad de género mientras
que los niños de escuelas primarias
deberán aprender sobre las diferentes
familias incluyendo las de la comunidad
lgbt
la ley que fue aprobada en el parlamento
de westminster el año pasado provocó
protestas en la ciudad inglesa de
birmingham por parte de un grupo de
padres de familia de la comunidad
musulmana que bloqueó durante meses el
acceso a una escuela primaria para
evitar que la diversidad sexual sea
enseñada en las escuelas
[Música]
a menos de una semana al comienzo
oficial del año escolar en italia con la
reapertura de escuelas colegios y
universidades el país se prepara para
una revolución pedagógica en la era de
la educación postpandemia italia se
convertirá en el primer país del mundo
que incluirá en su programa de estudios
la materia del cambio climático y el
desarrollo sostenible una hora semanal
obligatoria para todos los alumnos de
los colegios italianos el proyecto
también prevé que materias como física
geografía y matemática se estudian desde
el punto de vista del desarrollo
sostenible todo esto con un objetivo
despertar la conciencia ecológica en los
ciudadanos italianos del futuro